This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. A few years ago, on Estacia Marx till Salcedo was making lunch for her kids. And so like most moms, I do a lot of lunches. And when I do that, I usually try and find a balance between healthy and not so healthy. On the not quite so healthy side, she might pack some cheesy crackers, and on the healthy side, she'd make her kids a sandwich. Or at least, she thought the sandwiches that she was making were healthy, until she looked closely at the ingredients. I realized that I'd pulled the package deli me out of my fridge, that the bread came
这里是《99% Invisible》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。几年前，阿纳斯塔西娅·马克斯·德尔·萨尔塞多（Anastasia Marx de Salcedo）正在为她的孩子们准备午餐。“像大多数妈妈一样，我经常准备午餐。我通常会试着在健康和不那么健康之间找到平衡。”在不太健康的那一侧，她可能会装一些芝士饼干；而在健康的那一侧，她会给孩子们做三明治。或者至少，她认为自己做的三明治是健康的，直到她仔细看了看配料表。“我意识到我从冰箱里拿出的包装熟食肉，还有面包……”
from my bread box, and I've been sitting there for a while, and I've been sitting in the supermarket, and then had been manufactured way back when. And Anastasia got to thinking, it is kind of unnatural for food to last this long. Is this really a healthy lunch? That's Tina Antillini, host of the podcast Gravy, helping us tell the story. Anastasia looked at the package deli meat,
“……来自我的面包箱，它已经在那里放了一段时间，在超市里也放了一段时间，而且是很久以前生产的。”阿纳斯塔西娅开始思考：食物能保存这么久，这有点不自然。这真的是一份健康的午餐吗？那是播客《Gravy》的主持人蒂娜·安蒂利尼（Tina Antillini），她正在帮我们讲述这个故事。阿纳斯塔西娅看着包装好的熟食肉、
the store-bought sliced bread, the processed cheese. As it happens, she's a journalist. She writes a lot about food. And so she started looking into it. I went through all of those ingredients that you just listened to, including the mustard and the mayonnaise. And at least two of the items, the package deli meat and the supermarket bread, took her research ultimately
超市买的切片面包和加工奶酪。碰巧，她是一位记者。她写了很多关于食物的文章。于是她开始深入研究。“我仔细检查了你们刚才听到的所有配料，包括芥末和蛋黄酱。其中至少有两样东西，即包装熟食肉和超市面包，最终让她的研究……”
to this obscure US army base, the NADIC Soldier System Center. This is very strange. What is the army doing in food? What the army is doing in food is, of course, feeding the troops. And by strange extension, you and me. Military organizations have actually been involved in food production ever since the earliest combat rations. The first combat rations were probably eaten by the Sumerians.
“……指向了这个鲜为人知的美国陆军基地——纳蒂克士兵系统中心（NSRDEC）。”这非常奇怪。军队在食品领域做什么？军队在食品领域所做的，当然是为部队提供补给。而通过一种奇怪的延伸，也包括你和我。事实上，自最早的作战口粮出现以来，军事组织就一直参与食品生产。最早的作战口粮可能是苏美尔人吃的。
They did carry with them into battle, barley cakes, beer, and green onions. Back in the early days of organized warfare, if you were marching into battle and didn't know when you'd get home again, you needed to bring something that would keep. All of these rations were based on traditional methods of preserving food, drying, saltine, smoking, and pickling. But the real innovation was coming up with a preserved protein. Ancient Egyptians went to war carrying dried fish with them. And in the 11th and 12th centuries the Mongols preserved their meat by storing it under their saddles. And the salt from the horse would enter the meat and the
他们在战斗中随身携带大麦饼、啤酒和青葱。在有组织战争的早期，如果你要行军打仗，又不知道什么时候能回家，你就需要带上能保存的东西。所有这些口粮都基于传统的食物保存方法：干燥、腌制、烟熏和酸渍。但真正的创新在于蛋白质的保存。古埃及人去打仗时会带着鱼干。而在11和12世纪，蒙古人通过把肉放在马鞍下保存。马身上的盐分会进入肉里，而且……
the pressure of the rider's weight would push the meat down and that would actually create this preserved meat. So that that's kind of salted by horse sweat and compressed by your butt on the saddle. Mongolian methods aside for some 2000 years, military food rations pretty much stayed the same. Flower, beans, a hunk of salted meat, and some heart attack, a kind of twice baked biscuit. Or in the case of Napoleon's army, soldiers would just go plunder the countryside and eat whatever they found.
“……骑手的重量会把肉压紧，这实际上就创造了这种腌制肉。”所以，这是一种被马汗腌制、被你屁股在马鞍上压紧的肉。撇开蒙古人的方法不谈，大约2000年来，军队的口粮基本保持不变。面粉、豆类、一块腌肉和一些硬饼干（一种烤两次的饼干）。或者在拿破仑军队的情况下，士兵们只是去掠夺乡村，吃他们能找到的任何东西。
Which became a problem when soldiers went MIA trying to get food when there was a battle to fight. And so in 1795, the French government and the agriculture department decided they needed a new way to preserve food for the troops. They announced a contest, 12,000 francs to anyone who could come up with a new method. A man named Nicholas Appair responded. He was, at the time, the celebrity chef. He cooked for kings and queens.
当士兵们为了找食物而失踪，导致无法参加战斗时，这就成了问题。因此，在1795年，法国政府和农业部门决定他们需要一种为部队保存食物的新方法。他们宣布了一场竞赛，奖励12000法郎给任何能提出新方法的人。一个名叫尼古拉·阿佩尔（Nicholas Appert）的人做出了回应。他当时是一位名厨。他为国王和王后烹饪。
And a pair found a way to cook and preserve food using glass and metal containers. This is canning, and it revolutionized the world. This was the first time that a military had taken on a big problem in food technology and solved it. And militaries would continue to innovate around food for soldiers and sailors. Fast forward to World War II in the United States. During World War II, the country had to ramp up from feeding 400,000 soldiers to ultimately 11.6 million. American troops had packs of meat and cheese and crackers,
阿佩尔找到了一种使用玻璃和金属容器烹饪和保存食物的方法。这就是罐头，它彻底改变了世界。这是军队第一次承担食品技术方面的重大问题并解决了它。此后，军队将继续围绕士兵和水手的食物进行创新。快进到二战时期的美国。二战期间，美国必须将供养40万士兵的能力提升到最终的1160万。美国军队有肉类、奶酪和饼干的包装，
as well as canned goods, of course. But these Russians didn't survive the rigors of war too well. And they really hadn't been sufficient to feed so many soldiers in so many different locations, in so many different climates and conditions. The military had been unprepared to feed their soldiers during World War II. The government said, well you know what?
当然还有罐头食品。但这些口粮在战争的严酷考验下并没有很好地保存下来。而且它们确实不足以在这么多不同的地点、这么多不同的气候和条件下供养如此多的士兵。军队在二战期间没有做好供养士兵的准备。政府说，好吧，你知道吗？
We don't ever want to have to go through this again. It was just horrible to have to ramp up. So let's maintain ourselves in a state of preparedness. And so preparedness became policy after World War II. To support that, they created a system of 700 federal laboratories, And so preparedness became policy after World War II. To support that, they created a system of 700 federal laboratories all devoted to developing military technologies. And one of them is the NADIC Soldier System Center outside of Boston.
我们再也不想经历这种情况了。不得不临时扩充规模真是太可怕了。所以让我们保持一种战备状态。于是，战备在二战后成为了政策。为了支持这一点，他们建立了一个由700个联邦实验室组成的系统，所有这些实验室都致力于开发军事技术。其中之一就是波士顿郊外的纳蒂克士兵系统中心。
So, this looks pretty much like suburbia with the exception of the intense electric fence. Except for that barbed-wire fence in the guard posted at the gate, the Nadex Soldier System Center looks like a normal office park. But this office park is the epicenter of the modern military diet. It is the home of the combat feeding directorate, which has been here since the 1950s. First of all, can I have you introduce yourself to me? Absolutely, I'm Stephen Moody, the director of combat feeding here at the Nadex soldier research development and engineering center.
“所以，这看起来很像郊区，除了那道强力的电围栏。”除了那道铁丝网围栏和门口的警卫哨所，纳蒂克士兵系统中心看起来就像一个普通的办公园区。但这个办公园区是现代军事饮食的中心。它是战斗口粮管理局（Combat Feeding Directorate）的所在地，自20世纪50年代以来一直在这里。“首先，能请你做个自我介绍吗？”“当然，我是斯蒂芬·穆迪（Stephen Moody），纳蒂克士兵研究、开发和工程中心战斗口粮部门的主任。”
Stephen showed me how military food technology has evolved over time. Cans, for instance, have since been replaced by flexible lined pouches, because cans are bulky and heavy. And since the 1980s troops have been eating their meals out of those pouches, in what are called MREs, meals ready to eat. The first MRE contained a lot of freeze-dried components, a freeze-dried meat patty that you would have to add water to, and then heat it, and having eaten a few of those in my time as an active duty soldier. It had to get it just right. It was always either a little bit too soggy or a little bit
斯蒂芬向我展示了军事食品技术是如何随时间演变的。例如，罐头已经被柔性内衬袋所取代，因为罐头又大又重。自20世纪80年代以来，部队一直从这些袋子里吃东西，这就是所谓的MRE（即食口粮）。第一代MRE包含许多冷冻干燥成分，一种你需要加水然后加热的冷冻干燥肉饼，作为一名现役士兵，我吃过几次。你必须掌握好火候。它总是要么有点太软，要么……
crunchy at the end of the day. Ever since World War II, the combat feeding directorate has been tasked with overcoming certain challenges inherent in food. It spoils, it grows mold, it loses flavor. And if you're trying to feed a vast number of people and climates ranging from the desert to the humid jungle over a long periods of time, you have to figure out ways of making food that will avoid its natural tendency to go bad. So the combat feeding directorate has whole teams of microbiologists, engineers, and other scientists working to extend to the lives of foods. Food engineering preservation and stabilization, for instance, would be the ones that would
“……到最后还是脆的。”自二战以来，战斗口粮管理局一直致力于克服食物中固有的某些挑战。它会变质，会长霉，会失去风味。如果你试图在从沙漠到潮湿丛林等各种气候下，在很长一段时间内供养大量的人，你就必须想出办法来制造出能避免其自然变质倾向的食物。因此，战斗口粮管理局有整个微生物学家、工程师和其他科学家团队致力于延长食物的保质期。例如，食品工程保存和稳定化部门，就是那些会……
try to figure out how to make that product shelf stable for two, three, five years without refrigeration exactly. And then there's the little detail of taste, making this stuff actually palatable. The modern MRE has come a long way from that chewy freeze-dried meat patty. Today's high-tech pouches come with another pouch that chemically heats the ration. The US military now offers 24 different entrees, from cheese tortellini to lemon pepper tuna to jambalaya. On the Jambalaya, for instance, trying to make sure that Jambalaya would last for three years at 80 degrees in a pouch is a challenge.
“……试图弄清楚如何使产品在不冷藏的情况下保质两、三、五年。”然后还有一个关于味道的小细节，让这些东西真正可口。现代MRE已经从那种耐嚼的冷冻干燥肉饼走了很长一段路。今天的高科技袋子配有另一个袋子，可以通过化学反应加热口粮。美国军方现在提供24种不同的主菜，从芝士饺子到柠檬胡椒金枪鱼，再到什锦饭。以什锦饭为例，试图确保什锦饭在袋子里在80度下能保存三年是一个挑战。
So we tweak the spices, we tweak the ingredients so that we can make sure that the flavor is optimal at the end of the shelf life as well as the beginning. So that soldier on a mountain in Afghanistan can enjoy a flexible pouch of three-year-old jambalaya. I mean, that's the goal. But it's not always the reality when you open an MRE. So it was just like just gelatinous barbecue beef that had this pungent smell to it. Louisiana native Ben Armstrong spent five years
“所以我们调整香料，调整配料，这样我们就能确保在保质期结束时和开始时味道一样好。”这样，在阿富汗山上的士兵就能享用一袋三年的什锦饭。我的意思是，这就是目标。但当你打开MRE时，现实并不总是这样。“它就像那种有刺鼻气味的胶状烧烤牛肉。”路易斯安那州本地人本·阿姆斯特朗（Ben Armstrong）在海军陆战队待了五年。
in the Marine Corps. Don't even get him started on the John Belaya MRE for a Louisiana. Well, it's just sacrilege. I would never try it. And so the military isn't just working on MREs. They're also trying to develop foods that look and taste more like,
别让他开始谈论路易斯安那州的什锦饭MRE。“嗯，这简直是亵渎。我永远不会尝试它。”所以军方不仅仅是在研究MRE。他们还在努力开发看起来和吃起来更像……
you know what you eat at 3 a.m. You're like really, really hungry and your judgment is somewhat impaired. We actually took something like a hot pocket that you'd find in the freezer at the grocery store and made one that was shelf stable. And we did that by controlling the water activity and the pH of the different components within the product so that they wouldn't allow bacteria to grow. They packaged it up with something called an oxygen scavenger,
“……你知道你在凌晨3点吃的那种东西。你真的、真的很饿，而且你的判断力有点受损。”“我们实际上拿了一种你在杂货店冷冻柜里能找到的披萨口袋（Hot Pocket），并制作了一种常温保存的。我们通过控制产品中不同成分的水分活度和pH值来做到这一点，这样它们就不会让细菌生长。”他们用一种叫做除氧剂的东西包装它，
a little packet of iron filings that absorbs oxygen, keeping it away from the bread. So mold wouldn't grow on the bread. And we designed hurdles to each step within the process that might allow spoilage to the point where we now have a sandwich that will last for three years at room temperature. And this leads us to the holy grail of military food science.
一小包铁粉，可以吸收氧气，使其远离面包。这样面包就不会发霉。我们为过程中的每一步都设计了障碍，以防止变质，以至于我们现在有一种可以在室温下保存三年的三明治。这把我们引向了军事食品科学的圣杯。
An item that soldiers have been requesting since time immemorial... pizza. Pizza that is shelf stable for three years. This is our pilot plan. Stephen took me inside a massive industrial kitchen full of giant kettles, mixers, ovens. I see a worker in a lab coat and hair net standing over an enormous pot stirring vigorously. What, hi. It's cooking. Hi, we're going to some pizza sauce.
“一种士兵从远古时代就一直要求的食物……披萨。一种可以常温保存三年的披萨。”“这是我们的试点工厂。”斯蒂芬带我走进了一个巨大的工业厨房，里面满是巨大的水壶、搅拌机和烤箱。我看到一个穿着实验服、戴着发网的工人站在一个巨大的锅前用力搅拌。“嗨，你好。正在做饭。”“嗨，我们要准备一些披萨酱。”
In another corner of the pilot plant, a different worker is slicing up a pizza topping that at first I thought I misheard. Did you call this Osmo Roni? You call it Osmo Roni. Osmo Roni. Osmo Roni. Osmo-roni. Osmo-roni.
在试点工厂的另一个角落，另一名工人正在切一种披萨配料，起初我以为我听错了。“你管这个叫Osmo Roni吗？”“你管它叫Osmo Roni。”“Osmo Roni。”“Osmo-roni。”“Osmo-roni。”
Osmo-roni, or Osmotic pepperoni, looks like a roll of toilet paper made of meat. A thin sheet of beef rolled up with a layer of plastic to prevent it from sticking to itself. It's preserved using osmotic dehydration. The technology basically involves running thin sheets of meat through a special water bath that removes water from the meat itself, preserving it. I tasted it. I probably if somebody had just served me that I would not have even questioned what it was. No, no you wouldn't. I mean, it tastes like pepperoni. I would probably increase the amount of pepperoni flavor, but those are some of the things that we're working on. The army is aiming to have shelf-stable pizza in combat zones by 2017, and maybe soon after
Osmo-roni，或者叫渗透性意大利辣香肠，看起来像一卷肉做的卫生纸。一张薄薄的牛肉片，卷着一层塑料，以防止它粘在一起。它是使用渗透脱水技术保存的。这项技术基本上包括将薄肉片通过特殊的盐水浴，去除肉本身的水分，从而保存它。我尝了尝。“如果有人只是端给我吃，我甚至不会怀疑它是什么。”“不，不，你不会的。我的意思是，它尝起来就像意大利辣香肠。我可能会增加意大利辣香肠的味道，但这些是我们正在研究的一些东西。”军方目标是在2017年之前让作战区域拥有常温保存的披萨，也许在那之后不久……
that, in your local grocery store. This is another part of the combat feeding directorate, ever since its origins after World War II. When the military decided it needed to create a backup plant to feed troops in the event of a sudden war. And so the US government made it a requirement for these labs to share their findings with the commercial sector. What we try to do when we come up with a new technology is make sure that it's not
“……在你的当地杂货店里。”这是战斗口粮管理局的另一部分，自二战后起源以来一直如此。当时军方决定需要建立一个后备计划，以便在突然爆发战争时供养部队。因此，美国政府要求这些实验室与商业部门分享他们的发现。“当我们提出一项新技术时，我们尽量确保它不是……”
military specific, so that there are commercial applications for it. And that can only help us with economies of scale. If something is military unique and it's only produced for the US military, the costs are going to be a lot higher than if it's produced for the commercial sector as well. And it's not just costs. If there's ever a large demand for these combat rations, like in a time of war, it's good for the military if there are companies out there that already have the technology to make these kinds of products.
“……军事特定的，这样它就有商业应用。这只能通过规模经济来帮助我们。如果某样东西是军事独有的，并且只为美国军方生产，那么成本将比为商业部门生产要高得多。”而且不仅仅是成本。如果对这些作战口粮有巨大的需求，比如在战争时期，如果外面有公司已经拥有制造这些产品的技术，这对军方是有利的。
And of course, if the private sector has these technologies, they'll use them. On us. This means there's evidence of the army's influence all over the Gris' Reiles. For example, your children can thank the armed services for their favorite food, mac and cheese. Cheese powder in the mac and cheese, and then you'd have also an army cheesy snack foods that might be around. Anastasia Mark's Dicell Sado took all of her research, starting with her children's lunch, and wrote a book called Combat Ready Kitchen, how the US military shapes the way you eat. So at this point, she can walk into a grocery store and point out all the foods that have
当然，如果私营部门拥有这些技术，他们就会使用它们。用在我们身上。这意味着军队的影响力在杂货店里随处可见。例如，你的孩子可以感谢武装部队为他们提供了他们最喜欢的食物——通心粉和奶酪。通心粉和奶酪里的芝士粉，还有你可能在周围看到的军队芝士零食。阿纳斯塔西娅·马克斯·德尔·萨尔塞多从她孩子的午餐开始，完成了所有的研究，并写了一本名为《战斗准备厨房：美国军方如何塑造你的饮食方式》的书。所以此时，她可以走进一家杂货店，指出所有带有……
the military's fingerprints on them, which is exactly what she did with me. We've got some TV dinners. Turkey Tetruthsini and Meatloaf and gravy and Turkey Pot Pie. The TV dinner, the frozen entree was developed by an army contractor to feed bomber troops on overseas flights. And this prompted the military to come up
“……军方指纹的食物。”这正是她和我一起做的事情。“我们有一些电视晚餐。火鸡四重奏、肉饼和肉汁，还有火鸡派。”电视晚餐，这种冷冻主菜是由一名军队承包商开发的，旨在为海外飞行中的轰炸机部队提供食物。这促使军方想出了……
with what became the microwave. Yes, the microwave is a military innovation. The military also developed freeze-drying technology, so instant coffee, teas, soups. The army also hit upon a game changer, but they call intermediate moisture foods. Foods that are moist and also bacteria resistant. You see this in energy bars, pillowy sliced bread and packaged cookies. One thing that cookie makers did is once they understood the scientific they started
“……后来成为微波炉的东西。是的，微波炉是一项军事创新。”军方还开发了冷冻干燥技术，所以有了速溶咖啡、茶、汤。军队还发现了一个改变游戏规则的东西，但他们称之为中间水分食品。既湿润又抗细菌的食物。你在能量棒、松软的切片面包和包装饼干中可以看到这一点。饼干制造商所做的一件事是，一旦他们理解了科学，他们就开始……
and making this often chewy cookies in the olden days, supermarket things would be crisp. As we go through the grocery store, Anastasia stops and squeezes packages. She gets excited about a package of Thai basil and sweet chili stir-fry sauce. Okay, the reason I feel it up is that to feel the packaging. This is a retort pouch, which was developed by the Nadex Hunter. Those flexible pouches are the same packaging from the MREs, but now it's for squeezy applesauce
“……制作这种柔软耐嚼的饼干。在过去，超市里的东西会很脆。”当我们走过杂货店时，阿纳斯塔西娅停下来挤压包装。她对一包泰式罗勒和甜辣炒酱感到兴奋。“好吧，我摸它的原因是感受包装。这是一种蒸煮袋，是由纳蒂克中心开发的。”那些柔性袋子和MRE里的包装是一样的，但现在它用于挤压苹果酱……
and yogurts, tuna and sauce packets. It can start to be a little bit haunting as you go grocery shopping, the military everywhere. I started to feel like I was walking around looking at ghosts of conber Russians. I think about it when I'm with my kids because they do seem to prefer those. It's not just Anastasia's kids.
“……和酸奶、金枪鱼和酱料包。”当你去杂货店购物时，这开始变得有点令人难以忘怀，到处都是军队的影子。我开始觉得我走来走去，看着作战口粮的幽灵。当我和孩子们在一起时，我会想到这一点，因为他们似乎确实更喜欢那些。“这不仅仅是阿纳斯塔西娅的孩子们。”
These food products are beloved and ubiquitous. From Cheetos to Chewy granola bars, military innovations have a tendency to get worked into our diets. And most people don't stop to question how a packaged cookie can remain soft for eternity. And I think most consumers say, hey, it comes in the package to the company, says it's okay, I'm not going to worry about it, and we go for that. Anastasia says it's unclear how or if these food preservation techniques are affecting our health.
这些食品深受喜爱且无处不在。从奇多（Cheetos）到耐嚼的燕麦棒，军事创新往往会融入我们的饮食中。大多数人不会停下来质疑为什么一包饼干可以永远保持柔软。我认为大多数消费者会说，嘿，它是包装好的，公司说没问题，我不会担心的，我们就买了。阿纳斯塔西娅说，目前还不清楚这些食品保存技术是如何或是否在影响我们的健康。
There are a lot of ways that the military has changed the chemistry of different foods, and not all of them have been studied. But she's definitely hesitating before putting these types of foods in her kids' lunches. The average civilian doesn't need food to stay preserved for years at a time, but it's showing up on our shelves thanks to the military and we're buying it. This is what we're given, the shelf stable and the mold resistant, meticulously designed to simulate the fresh and the familiar. So if in a few years you happen to buy a shelf-stable pizza in your local supermarket, be prepared, that pepperoni might actually be... osmironi.
“军方改变不同食物化学成分的方法有很多，并不是所有的方法都经过研究。”但她在把这些类型的食物放进孩子们的午餐盒之前肯定会犹豫。普通平民不需要食物保存数年之久，但多亏了军方，它出现在了我们的货架上，而我们正在购买它。这就是我们所得到的，常温保存和抗霉菌，经过精心设计以模拟新鲜和熟悉的感觉。所以，如果几年后你碰巧在当地超市买到了一份常温保存的披萨，请做好准备，那意大利辣香肠可能实际上是……Osmo-roni。
99% invisible was produced this week by Tina Antillini, with Avery Truffleman, Katie Mingle, Sam Greenspan, Kurt Colstad, and me Roman Mars. Tina Antillini hosts the podcast Gravy, which is a production of the Southern Foodways Alliance. You can check it out at SouthernFoodways.org-slashgravy. You can find a link to Anastasia Marks Del Salcedos book combat ready kitchen how the US military shapes the way you eat on our website that's 99pi.org. 99% of visible is a project of KALW in San Francisco and produced out of the offices of
《99% Invisible》本周由蒂娜·安蒂利尼制作，艾弗里·特鲁夫曼、凯蒂·明格、萨姆·格林斯潘、库尔特·科尔斯塔德和我罗曼·马尔斯参与。蒂娜·安蒂利尼主持播客《Gravy》，这是南方饮食方式联盟（Southern Foodways Alliance）的作品。你可以在 SouthernFoodways.org/gravy 上查看。你可以在我们的网站上找到阿纳斯塔西娅·马克斯·德尔·萨尔塞多的书《战斗准备厨房：美国军方如何塑造你的饮食方式》的链接，网址是 99pi.org。《99% Invisible》是旧金山 KALW 的一个项目，在……的办公室制作。
Arxine, an architecture in interiors firm in beautiful downtown Oakland, California. Radio Tapio. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
Arxine，一家位于加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心美丽的建筑和室内设计公司。Radio Tapio。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。